[Música]
hola hola a todos gracias por estar aquí
yo siempre he pensado que cuando la
gente se da la oportunidad de escuchar a
los demás algo se le queda en la cabeza
y hoy
oportunidad se la estamos pidiendo a la
coca
ayer fue 19 de octubre
mi hermano cumple 12 años de haber sido
asesinado en popayán yo estaba
trabajando en bolivia hace 12 años con
productores cocaleros y a mí me llamaron
a decirme que lo habían asesinado
cuando volví a colombia un mes después
fui a la fiscalía a preguntar cómo iba
el caso de mi hermano pregunté bueno qué
pasó con mi hermano la fiscal me dijo
que no me preocupara que finalmente a él
lo habían asesinado por ser consumidor
de sustancias
al fin y al cabo era un marihuanero
qué importaba
ese día yo entendí que definitivamente
el universo es perfecto
y entendí que los productores de hoja de
coca
y los consumidores de todas las
sustancias derivadas de ella
son simplemente extremos de una misma
línea
que si se juntan pueden generar un
espacio casi como el infinito
a partir de ese momento entendí que
tanto los productores de hojas de coca
como los transformadores como los
consumidores finales merecen una
oportunidad
y merecen dos cosas investigación y
educación
a partir de allí y con el respaldo de
escena regional cauca empecé un trabajo
de investigación sobre cómo modificar la
visión que tenemos sobre la hoja de coca
resultado de esta investigación es lo
que estamos promoviendo en este momento
y lo que les queremos contar esta noche
la coca en su estado natural es de uso
tradicional en los andes' americanos
todos los indígenas andinos han tenido
la costumbre del mambo del saqueo del
acullicu y acompañado de la coca desde
las momias que tenemos hace cerca de
3000 años hay evidencias previas a
cristo 3000 años previos a cristo hay
evidencias de coca en las estructuras
bucales y en las momias encontradas en
los andes
tenemos dos especies con dos variedades
cada una hay muchas más especies de coca
en todos los andes' vienen desde méxico
hasta el norte de argentina pero
solamente de cuatro especies y puedes
sacar cocaína del resto podemos sacar
todos los nutrientes que necesitamos
para vivir
mírenla lo bonita mírenla lo bonita que
es es una preciosa flor perfecta que nos
da la oportunidad de pensar que puede
ser inofensiva ella es inofensiva
ella no daña a nadie ella solamente es
una planta más dentro del ecosistema y
de la biodiversidad que tenemos
y tiene de todo la coca es cocaína sí
pero la coca también es tradición la
coca es cultura andina la coca es una
oportunidad para hacer comida la coca
tiene nutrientes tiene proteína cruda
tiene calcio tiene nitrógeno tiene una
cantidad de cosas que nos hemos negado a
estudiar por eso necesitamos que cada
persona que tiene un vínculo con la coca
sea fuerte y empiece a aprender cosas
distintas de ella
la coca
transformada nos puede arrojar más de
150 productos en el caso de los de los
ejercicios que estamos haciendo con el
sena hemos desarrollado 5 productos
básicos harina de coca abonos
chocolatería galletería toda la sección
de pastelería
con quién hacemos esto con hombres y
mujeres campesinos productores de hoja
de coca especialmente la gente de leer
cauca hermana es un corregimiento en el
centro del municipio de bolívar
nos reunimos con frecuencia durante todo
el año y tratamos de construir nuevas
visiones sobre la hoja de coca
nosotros que queremos queremos que nos
dé una oportunidad queremos que podamos
tranquilamente empezar a consumir
productos derivados de hoja de coca que
sean diferentes a la cocaína claro que
sabemos que esta no es la única opción
claro que sabemos que a punta de
galletas no vamos a consumir las 180.000
hectáreas que hay hoy sembradas con hoja
de coca y que tal vez no vamos a poder
afectar a las 80.000 familias asociadas
a esta producción pero sí sabemos que si
tenemos 30 familias y alcanzamos una
meta de 150 familias en cada
corregimiento vamos a poder tener una
oportunidad para estas familias y vamos
a tener la posibilidad de poder generar
ingresos diferenciados autónomos y
soberanos que nos permitan manejar de
una manera distinta a los territorios
este es el territorio de paz y
convivencia de bolívar cauca y esta es
la propuesta que tenemos necesitamos
urgentemente que las políticas públicas
cambien porque necesitamos tener la
oportunidad de trabajar con la hoja de
coca en un esfuerzo interinstitucional
que hemos hecho hemos logrado tener el
primer permiso de investigación que nos
permite hacer compra local de hoja de
coca
esto nos hace ser pioneros a nivel
nacional y darle la oportunidad a la
gente de que en vez de ir a venderle al
narco baje la hoja de coca y no la venda
a nosotros y la transformamos de manera
local en abonos en comida en harinas y
muchas veces
y recomponiendo nuestra memoria en las
zonas más alejadas podemos entender que
podemos hasta salir con la porción de
coca para poder comer durante el día y
retornar a la casa a comer la única
escena que muchas personas tienen en la
zona rural
hay muchísima gente comprometida en este
trabajo son más de 25 instructores del
sena regional cauca son más de 30
familias en lerma
pero además son muchas fundaciones y
organizaciones que le han apostado a
sacar esto adelante la fundación tierra
de paz bueno ahí hay financiadores
internacionales pero saben que sobre
todo son personas como ustedes como yo
como mis hijos o mis sobrinos que se dan
la oportunidad de comerse una galletita
la galletita no pasa nada no los va a
trabajar no van a tener ningún lamento
decepcionarlos pero no se van a trabajar
a la galletita que tenemos y que hacemos
la podemos comer con un poquito de
limonada y nos va a dar la energía para
aguantar una tarde de trabajo entonces
la invitación es a esa que cuando
ustedes vean productos elaborados de
hoja de coca hechos por campesinos de
las zonas cocaleras que están tratando
de hacer resistencia política social y
económica a este gran monstruo que es el
narcotráfico que se quiere comer todo lo
que tenemos en las zonas rurales démosle
la oportunidad quite müller esa libra
de hoja de coca al narcotráfico y
convirtamos la en comida para nuestras
familias
quitémosle es a esa familia arranquemos
el al narcotráfico comprando los
productos que está elaborando entonces
la invitación es a eso a quien no
comamos cuento a que comamos coca ya que
vamos a la casita y el saludemos a la
abuelita y le preguntemos a la abuela
vea usted para qué era que usaba la coca
en la casa y se van a dar cuenta todos
ustedes que estamos en la región del
suroccidente colombiano que las abuelas
para todos nos daban coca esa es la
invitación espero que vengan y gracias
violeta por aguantar todo el día y por
ser tan juiciosa
coman coca ella come coca
[Aplausos]